امراه استثنائيه تدير الاموال وتجني
المليارات تبيع الاسهم وتشتريها اجتهدت
على نفسها فصنعت لها اسما كبيرا في عالم
الاستثمار وباتت واحده من السيدات الاكثر
ثراء في العالم انها ابيكال جونسون ملكه
الحصص الاكبر في شركه فيدلتي فما قصتها
ولدت عام
1961 في بوسطن وهي تنتمي لعائله ذات جذور
في التجاره منذ اوائل القرن التاسع عشر
فجدها ادوارسيه المعروف بجونسون الثاني
مؤسس احدى اهم شركات الاستثمارات في
العالم والتمويل المشترك في عام
1946 اسس جونسون الثاني شركه الصناديق
المشتركه
ونجح في جذب المستثمرين في السوق الماليه
واداره اموالهم وبفضل حنكته نمت الشركه
بشكل كبير في سوق الاسهم خلال الثمانينيات
والتسعينيات واصبحت احدى اهم شركات القطاع
الماليه وعندما قرر التقاعد في عام
1977 تنازل عن اداره الشركه لابنه جونسون
الثالث بعد ان انهت الحفيده المتحمسه
ابيجال مرحله الدراسه الثانويه في عام
1980 انضمت للشركه واظهرت تحديا كبيرا في
التوفيق بين عملها بخدمه العملاء ودراستها
تاريخ الفن قبل ان تغير توجهها وتلتحق
بكليه هارفارد للاعمال وتحصد درجه
الماجستير في اداره الاعمال ما منحها فرصه
لبدء وظيفتها كمحلل اسهم في عام
1994 ترقى والد ابدا لمنصب مساعد مدير
الشركه وهو ما دفعه للتفكير في رفع اسهمه
بشركه حيث بات المساهم الاكبر فيها فيما
كانت تتدرج وهي بالوظائف الى ان اصبحت رئي
هذا قسم الصناديق المشتركه وصاحبه القرار
رقم ثلاثه في الشركه بعد والدها ومدير
العمليات بالشركه ثم خلفت ابيكال منصب
الرئيس التنفيذي منذ عام 2014 عندما تولت
منصب والدها وتولت منصب رئيس مجلس الاداره
منذ عام 2016 اثناء شغلها المناصب
الاداريه واجهت ابيجل تحديات كبيره ابرزها
المخاوف من هبوط قيم الاسهم المتضرره
ودخول منافسين جدد بالسوق فعمدت الى اتخاذ
قرارات جريئه وغيرت استراتيجيات العمل كما
تبنت العمل بالعملات المشفره حيث اطلقت في
عام 2018 منصه تتيح للمستثمرين
تداول البيتكوين والايثاره ما اسهم في
الحفاظ على رياده الشركه التي تملك ما
يقدر بثلاثه ريونات وسبع مئه مليار دولار
من الاصول المدراء
[موسيقى]